bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du hasard
le hasard existe-t-il
c'est la caisse la sic la grande
question du hasard
typiquement le genre de question à
laquelle tout le monde a une réponse
alors le hasard existe-t-il parmi vous
certains répondront oui le hasard existe
le hasard existe et non seulement il
existe
mais il est même souvent l'élément
déterminant dans la survenue des
événements
être au bon endroit au bon moment au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
on en a tous déjà fait l'expérience
et on sait à quel point ça peut avoir
des conséquences
donc il y a bien dû au hasard il y à
bien des situations qui échappent à
notre contrôle
notre capacité d'anticipation
et puis d'ailleurs sans aller jusque là
s'il n'y avait pas de hasard
il n'y aurait pas de jeux de hasard
donc le hasard existe bel et bien
même une autre réponse consistera à dire
que non le hasard n'existe pas
et alors là il faut bien faire attention
parce qu'il ya deux raisons différentes
pour lesquelles on peut répondre au nom
on peut répondre peu le hasard n'existe
pas parce que tout est déterminé
romandie parce que tous les événements
font partie d'une longue chaîne de
causalité
d'une longue série de causes et d'effets
et donc le hasard ce n'est rien d'autre
que la somme des variables cachées
ce n'est rien d'autre que l'ensemble des
facteurs que nous ignorons
mais qui existent et qui participent aux
cours des événements
donc on appellera ça la réponse
déterministe
et puis il ya une autre manière de dire
que le hasard n'existe pas qui est la
réponse finalistes
qui consiste à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
hasard parce qu'il y a une volonté
supérieure
parce qu'il y a une puissance
gouvernante
qu'on l'appelle dieu on l'appelle le
destin
rappelle quelque chose
et que ce quelque chose serait en sorte
que les événements arrivent comme ils
doivent arriver
donc il n'ya pas de hasard
parce que tout a un sens
tout a une raison d'être
dans la religion on appelle ça à
providence
l'idée que tous participent à
l'exécution d'un grand plan divin dont
nous serions les participants et donc
lazare ne serait rien d'autre que le nom
qu'on donne à cette volonté supérieure
c'est l'idée qu'on retrouve dans la
phrase le hasard fait bien les choses
si le hasard fait bien les choses ça
veut dire que le hasard ne fait pas
n'importe quoi
qui n'est jamais aveugle et chaotique
le hasard serait le stratagème d'une
volonté supérieure
j'ai toujours en vue d'une finalité
je rappelle que le finalisme finalisme
finalité c'est l'idée qu'il y à un but
inscrit dans les choses
c'est l'idée par exemple que si nous
existons
c'est parce que quelque chose a voulu
que nous existions
car pourquoi existe aurions-nous
si nous n'étions pas issu d'une volonté
c'est ça la si pâle du finalisme la
question pourquoi
pourquoi au sens de pourquoi
le but
c'est parce qu'on attribue un but aux
choses qu'on ne croit pas au hasard
parce qu'on attribue une signification
aux événements
donc vous voyez qu'on peut pas croire au
hasard pour des raisons totalement
différentes et même pour des raisons
opposées
on peut ne pas croire au hasard parce
qu'on considère que tout est déterminé
parce qu'on considère que tout n'est
qu'en chaîne mangas sionnel de causes et
d'effets
ce qui semble totalement relever du
hasard même ceux dont les causes nous
échappe
mais on peut aussi ne pas croire au
hasard
ils ont philosophique ou spirituelle
parce qu'on considère qu'il y a dans les
événements qui arrivent la marque d'une
volonté supérieure qui agit dans notre
monde
alors on passe tu es sur chacune de ses
conceptions on va les analyser
et on va tenter voir dans quelle mesure
on peut les défendre
voir jusqu'à quel point ces conceptions
sont tenables
et surtout le plus important on va voir
quelle vision du monde il y a
chacune de ces conceptions
on va voir ce que notre conception du
hasard 10 de notre vision philosophique
du monde
alors pour on va déjà commencer par
définir le hasard
parce qu'on a tous une opinion plus ou
moins tranché sur le fait de savoir si
le hasard existe ou pas mais pour ça il
faut d'abord savoir de quoi on parle
quand on parle du hasard
alors le mot
rabe hasard
et ce mot désignait autrefois un jeu de
dés
ça l'origine du mot hasard
deux d
or quel est le principe du lancer de dés
et bien c'est justement le fait qu'on ne
puisse pas prédire le résultat du lancer
on peut parier sur le résultat
mais parier ça sous-entend qu'on n'en
sait rien
rien parce que ça ne dépend pas de notre
volonté
résultat dû lancer dès ce n'était pas
quelque chose dont nous avons la
maîtrise
c'est ça le hasard
c'est ce qui nous dépossède de notre
pouvoir de maîtrise
et donc on parlera de chance à chaque
fois qu'on aura parier sur le bon
résultat
lachance désignant le fait de gagner par
hasard c'est à dire
de gagner alors qu'on avait aucune
raison de gagner
donc ce qui définit le hasard
c'est l'un prédictibilité
le hasard c'est ce qui échappe à nos
capacités de maîtrise et donc de
prévisions
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que certaines
personnes qui ont besoin de tout
contrôler et ne veulent rien laisser au
hasard
parce que laisser les choses au hasard
c'est cesser de les maîtriser
c'est devenir le jouet du hasard
et alors là on soeur déjà un premier
problème
à savoir
qu'est ce qui diffère si le hasard
l'ignorance
parce que si le hasard c'est ce qu'il ya
sans qu'on l'ait voulu et donc sans
qu'on l'ait prévu sans qu'on ait pu
l'anticiper
alors dans ce cas là ça veut dire que le
hasard n'est pas tant une réalité qui
existerait en dehors de nous
que la marque de nos propres limites
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas quelque
chose dans le monde qui s'appellerait le
hasard et qui agirait dans notre dos
pour nous empêcher de maîtriser les
événements
s'il y a du hasard c'est parce qu'il y a
ignorance de la cause des événements
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
je veux dire par là que quand on joue
aux dés
à chaque fois qu'on lance les dés
on est bien d'accord qu'on ignore sur
quelle phase les dévents tomber
c'est tout l'intérêt du jeu
la question c'est pourquoi l'ignorent
non
on ignore parce qu'il ya trop de
paramètres à prendre en compte pour le
savoir
si on avait la capacité la capacité
intellectuelle la capacité analytique
de tenir compte de tous les paramètres
qui entrent en jeu dans le lancer dès
les paramètres physiques j'entends la
force du lancer sa direction
le frottement d'aidé sur le tapis bref
tous les paramètres qui font que chaque
des va tomber sur une face et pas sur
une autre
si on était en possession de toutes ces
variables infiniment subtil
on pourrait techniquement
prédire le résultat
mais c'est justement parce qu'on n'a pas
cette capacité
c'est justement parce qu'il ya trop de
paramètres à prendre en compte
qu'on parle de hasard
on parle de hasard parce que même si le
résultat du lancer est théoriquement
prévisible
il est humainement
imprévisible
s'il existait un appareil permettant de
scanner tout l'environnement physique au
moment où la main du joueur lâche le d
l'appareil pourrait prédire le résultat
parce que pour l'appareil le résultat
c'est simplement le produit d'un calcul
donc c'est en ce sens que je disais tout
à l'heure le hasard n'est pas tant une
réalité qui existe en dehors de nous
que la marque de notre propre ignorance
le hasard est toujours hasard du point
de vue humain
mais du point de vue d'un algorithme ou
du point de vue omniscient
n'y a pas de hasard
il n'y a que des données il n'y a que
des paramètres
et quand un algorithme n'arrive pas au
bon résultat
accès à cause du hasard
on en déduit que l'algorithme fonctionne
mal
on en déduit une défaillance
et bien
une défaillance que nous n'appellerons
rions pas hasard dans le cas d'un
algorithme
que nous appelons hasard dans le cas
d'un cerveau humain
différence
c'est seulement ça
et d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve de
sens c'est la tricherie
tricher c'est augmenter artificiellement
notre contrôle des paramètres
c'est s'octroyer des possibilités qui
aurait normalement dû être distribués
par le hasard
c'est parce qu'on sait que le hasard
nous échappe qu'on cherche à le
maîtriser en redéfinissant nous mêmes
les paramètres
et réduire l' influence du hasard dans
l'obtention d'un résultat on appelle ça
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
m o tout son côté ça veut justement dire
annuler la chance
tricher c'est remplacer le hasard par la
maîtrise
pour le supprimer
et donc dans le cas du lancer des ça
donne le petit filou qui est cette
grugés
qui lance le dé à l'horizontale ou à la
verticale
ou qui cherchent à faire un effet pour
que le déroule le moins possible
parce qu'un des qui roule c'est un des
qui peut s'arrêter sur la mauvaise passe
roulements de des sur le tapis
il y as augmentation du coefficient
d'incertitude
c'est pour ça qu'on retrouve avant cette
image de la roue dans les jeux de hasard
ce soit la roulette du casino
la bouteille tournante ou même la
roulette russe
puisque la roue c'est à la fois le
symbole du temps et du mouvement
si le symbole du destin et du hasard
c'est à dire
de ce qui échappe au pouvoir des hommes
et d'ailleurs c'est de là que vient le
nom du jeu télévisé la roue de la
fortune
la roue de la fortune contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire ce n'est pas la
roue de la richesse
c'est la roue du hasard
la fortune c'est ce qui est fortuit
c'est ça le sens initial du mot fortune
le hasard
et donc le hasard c'est le tombeau de la
stratégie
le hasard c'est ce qui rend inutile le
recours à nos compétences en calcul
parce qu'on ne possède pas toutes les
données de l'équation
parce qu'il nous manque des variables
et ces variables sont la forme
extérioriser de notre ignorance
on les appelle des variables parce qu'on
ne parvient pas à les isoler
c'est parce qu'on ignore certaines
informations qu'on les appelle des
variables
et donc la conclusion de tout ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est que s'il y a du
hasard c'est parce qu'il y à de
l'ignorance
le mot hazard sert uniquement à désigner
les causes que nous ignorons
autrement dit le h n'est pas l'inde est
terminée
celle indéterminable
le hasard n'est pas l'absence de cause
c'est l'ignorance des causes
le hasard est le nom de notre ignorance
et donc c'est là qu'on a arrive à la
caisse déterminisme
parce que souvenez vous de ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure je vous ai
dit qu'il y avait deux manières de
soutenir l'idée que le hasard n'existe
pas
soit parce qu'il y aurait un sens caché
derrière les événements on va y revenir
soit parce qu'on considère que tout ce
qui arrive est le résultat d'une longue
chaîne de causalité
c'est ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
quand je disais que le résultat du
lancer de dés dépend de plusieurs
facteurs
de la force de la direction et c'est
le résultat du lancer des c'est le
résultat de la conjonction de ces
facteurs
et bien c'est ça le déterminisme
c'est l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de hasard
parce que tout ce qui arrive est le
résultat d'une combinaison de cause
il n'y a pas de hasard
il n'y a que des causes connues ou
inconnues
c'était la position de spinoza
cette approche des ministres du monde
celle approche qui est privilégiée dans
les sciences
dans les mathématiques d'abord
parce que même si ça paraît évident il
faut rappeler qu'en mathématiques le
hasard est exclu
mais dans les sciences de la matière
aussi on exclut le hasard
en physique en chimie
le hasard n'est pas une variable de
l'équation
pourquoi et bien justement parce que la
matière c'est quelque chose dont on peut
maîtriser les paramètres
jusqu'à un certain niveau en tout cas
et disons que dans la vie de tous les
jours la matière se comporte de manière
suffisamment prévisible c'est à dire de
manière suffisamment régulières pour
qu'on puisse réussir à prédire son
comportement
la matière ne réagit pas de façon
aléatoire à ce qu'on lui fait subir
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il est
possible de formuler des lois physiques
si la matière réagissait de manière
aléatoire à ce qu'on lui fait subir
il n'y aurait pas de lois physiques
qu'il n'y aurait pas de régularité du
comportement de la matière
prenons un exemple
un stylo
prenez un stylo lâché le et observer son
comportement
recommencer et demandez vous comment
porte le stylo à chaque fois que je le
lâche
si tout va bien à chaque fois que vous
le lâcher le stylo tombe
bah
si vous répétez
encore et encore
peut-être qu'au bout de la millionième
fois
le stylo va tomber vers le haut
qui tu vas rester en apesanteur
on n'en sait rien
et bien si on sait
on sait que ce n'est pas possible
et comment on le sait on le sait parce
qu'il existe une loi qui
s'appelle la loi de la gravitation
qui fait que le stylo ne peut que tomber
vers le sol
s'était établi
c'est entièrement déterminées
dans les conditions estre la matière
tombe vers le sol
c'était pas une caisse hasard ou de
circonstance
c'est une loi
donc dans cette situation le hasard n'a
aucun espace pour s'infiltrer
il était
pas deux dans le comportement de la
matière parce qu existence d'une loi qui
déterminent le comportement de la
matière
alors bien sûr on parle de loi au sens
physique
ce n'est pas une loi décidée par les
hommes
il n'y a pas un code civil de la matière
qui dit à la matière comment elle doit
se comporter
une loi physique n'est pas une loi qui
prescrit mais une loi qui décrit
est ce que la loi de la gravitation
décrit c'est la régularité du
comportement de la matière
décor n'est pas un phénomène aléatoire
c'est un phénomène mécanique
alors ici n'est pas due
d'entrer dans des considérations sur la
physique quantique sur le fait de savoir
si le comportement de la matière ne
serait pas fondamentalement guider par
le hasard
avec le principe d'indétermination de
heisenberg et tout ce qui va avec
tout le propos
propose c'est tout simplement de dire
qu'à l'échelle de l'observateur
à l'échelle de notre rapport matériel au
monde
les phénomènes physiques sont régies par
des lois
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on peut parler
d'une conception déterministe de la
science
parce que dans une conception
déterministe les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets
donc si la matière obéit à la loi de la
gravitation qui fait qu un corps lourd
tombe vers le sol
il n'y a aucune raison de penser que la
prochaine fois
il en sera autrement
ce que pour qu'il en soit autrement il
faudrait que la loi qui régit ce
phénomène soit elle-même modifié
il faudrait que la gravitation cesse de
s'exercer
et ça se remarquerait
ce qu'il est intéressant de noter c'est
que
plus les objets que la science étudie
seront complexes
plus la science va nuancé son
déterminisme
la science nuance son déterminisme à
mesure que le nombre de paramètres
augmente
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'on n'étudie pas le
comportement d'un atome dans un
laboratoire
comme on étudie le comportement d'un
individu dans un milieu social
parce qu'un individu
main
c'est complexe
c'était pas mécaniques comme la matière
c'est plus subtil
la matière
globalement de manière mécanique je dis
bien globalement parce qu'on sait que
justement pas tout à fait mais dans
l'ensemble ce qui rend les phénomènes
matériel prédictible
qu'il s'inscrive dans une chaîne de
causalité visible et mesurable
et lorsqu un physicien fait ses
expériences dans son laboratoire il a la
maîtrise des paramètres
donc il n'ya pas de hasard
puisqu'il n'y a pas de gachet
le physique alors contempler le
déterminisme en pleine lumière
mais vie dure à l'individu humain
si on cherche à retracer la chaîne
causale qui a déterminé son comportement
bah là c'est plus compliqué
parce qu'on n'a plus à faire un simple
corps physique
on a affaire à une psychologie
on a affaire m ciot logis
à une éducation à une expérience à une
sensibilité
faire
un être complexe
un hêtre
pluridimensionnelle
et c'est certain
sion des différentes couches le
comportement humain qui va rendre
l'étude de ce comportement beaucoup plus
hasardeuses
au sens de soumise à un nombre de
variables beaucoup plus important
pour ne pas dire
incalculables
sans compter que chez les êtres humains
même causes ne produisent pas toujours
les mêmes effets
ça c'est le principe clé du déterminisme
scientifique les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets autrement dit si on
fait la même chose à un corps physique
il se comportera de la même manière à
chaque fois
chez les êtres humains un même événement
peut engendrer des conséquences
différentes pour l'individu
deux individus ne seront jamais affecté
exactement de la même manière par un
événement
il y aura toujours des nuances voire des
divergences
donc même si on applique une grille de
lecture déterministe au comportement
humain
on sait que le principe du déterminisme
s'applique à tous
le fait est que plus il y a deux
variables cachées qui entrent en jeu
dans une situation
plus le hasard prospère
le hasard prospère non pas parce que les
comportements humains n'obéirait a aucun
paramètre mais parce que ces paramètres
sont si nombreux et si subtile
qu'il nous échappe pour une large part
en
et là j'en profite pour dire quelques
mots sur l'effet papillon
l'effet papillon ne nous dit pas qu'un
battement d'aile de papillon au brésil
peut causer une tornade au texas
l'effet papillon ne dit qu'un battement
d'aile au brésil peut provoquer une
tornade
ok
n'est pas causée
provoquer c'est faire partie de la cause
si vous préférez le battement d'aile de
fillon ce n'est pas la cause de la
tornade
c'est une cause parmi un nombre infini
de cause
et c'est la conjonction de toutes ces
causes qui va rendre possible la tornade
et je dis ça parce que bien souvent dans
notre conception du principe de
causalité on a tendance à isoler les
paramètres
comme si les événements étaient le fruit
d'une seule cause
mais il n'y a jamais eu une seule cause
aux choses
ou plutôt chaque cause est une
combinaison de causes
chaque cause et le produit d'autres
causes
donc quand on pas fée papillon
dans quel cadre on utilise
les fait pas on ne nous dit pas que les
grands effets ont de petites causes
appuyons-nous dit que tous les micro
événement
que tous les nanos événements
une influence sur le cours des choses
l'effet papillon nous dit que des
événements aussi dérisoire en apparence
qu'un battement d'aile de papillon peut
avoir des répercussions à des milliers
de kilomètres
tout simplement parce que tout se
répercute sur tout
le moindre détail modifie tout
la moindre seconde modifie tout
c'est ça l'effet papillon
l'illustration de l'interpénétration des
causes et de l' influence de cette
interpénétration des causes sur le cours
des événements
on peut tous ceux constatés dans nos
vies
vous même
si au lieu de passer au feu orange il y
a cinq ans vous vous étiez arrêté
à venir je dis bien tout votre avenir
aurait été différent
vous auriez créer une deuxième ligne
temporelle
le vous qui s'est arrêté
et le vous qui
et et auraient une vie différente du
vous qui est passé
parce que ce petit décalage de 30
secondes au feu aurait engendré des
situations différentes dans les deux
chemins de vie
le mois qui s'est arrêtée au feu orange
n'aurait pas eu cet accident de
kilomètres plus loin
parce que trente secondes plus tard
celui qui m'est rentré dedans sur la
route n'était pas là
donc le vous qui s'est arrêtée n'aurait
pas eu la même vie que le vous qui est
passé
tout simplement parce qu en vous
arrêtant
vous avez reconfigurer les paramètres
vous avez influencer la chaîne de
causalité d'une manière plutôt que d'une
autre
un feu ange qu'on franchit où un feu
orange auxquelles on s'arrête c'est une
micro variations concret dans la chaîne
de causalité
et cette micro variations va affecter
l'ensemble des événements suivants
donc dites vous bien qu'à chaque fois
qu'il vous arrive quelque chose dans
votre vie vous le devez en partie
à ce feu orange
c'est ça la rai des des micro-événements
il nous amène beaucoup plus loin que ce
qu'on aurait imaginé
il y à un épisode de la série how i met
your mother où le héros rencontrent par
hasard la femme dont il va tomber
amoureux
et à la fin de l'épisode on le voit dire
merci à toutes les personnes qui se sont
trouvées sur son chemin durant cette
journée là
y compris à celui qui lui est passé
devant pour monter dans le taxi parce
que c'est grâce à ce taxi raté qu'il a
pris le chemin de l'arrêt de bus où il a
rencontré sa future femme
sié toutes les personnes qui se sont
trouvées sur sa route
c'est remercier la causalité
c'est remercier l'historique des causes
et des effets qui ont abouti à la
rencontre
donc pour ans amine et sur la conception
déterministe du hasard
sur quoi je voudrais vraiment un système
c'est que dans cette conception
pas de hasard
art n'est que le nom des causes que nous
ignorons
et c'est en cela que ironiquement la vie
nist un trait commun avec la vision
finalistes
puisque dans les deux camps
le hasard n'existe pas
la différence étant que pour les
déterministe c'est une causalité aveugle
j'ai les événements
une causalité 100 buts
tandis que pour les finalistes
c'est une causalité guider
c'est une causalité qui a un but
et c'est ce dont on va parler maintenant
dans la vie tout rond il arrive que des
événements se produisent des événements
qu'on appelle des coïncidences
et ces coïncidences vont produire en
nous
sentiment d'étonnement
un sentiment de stupeur
vous êtes assis à la terrasse d'un café
vous buvez votre verre en regardant
passer les gens
hélas parmi ces gens vous reconnaissez
quelqu'un avec qui vous étiez à l'école
primaire
incroyable
en fait non pas incroyable
surprenant oui au sens tout ce qui est
inattendu à quelque chose de surprenant
mais pas incroyable
parce que ben ça peut arriver
maintenant
imaginer que la ville dans laquelle vous
vous trouvez ce jour là
pas du tout la ville dans laquelle vous
avez grandi
retombé sur cette vieille connaissance
dans une autre vie que celle où vous
étiez à l'école
incroyable
alors n'ont toujours pas incroyable
mais déjà plus surprenant
en tout cas suffisamment surprenant pour
vous fassiez la réflexion
et maintenant il je n'ai que cette
vieille connaissance que vous rencontré
par hasard à la terrasse d'un café
aj n'est qu'à ce moment-là précis vous
étiez en train
de penser à elle
là c'est incroyable
là c'est incroyable parce que la
probabilité pour ça arrive est
extrêmement faible
c'est incroyable non pas parce que
l'événement est incroyable
mais parce qu'il était hautement
improbable
c'est ça qui rend le hasard plus ou
moins remarquable
son coefficient probabilités
et cse actair improbable de la situation
ce caractère extraordinaire
extraordinaire au sens littéral
au sens de ce qui sort de l'ordinaire
c'est ce caractère improbable qui fait
qu'on va naturellement se diriger vers
une interprétation finalistes
c'est à dire qu'on va rechercher un sens
à cette rencontre
un sens caché
ce qui ne peut être que métaphysique
parce qu'il faut l'intervention d'une
force métaphysique pour que les
variables de l'équation s'ajuste aussi
bien
c'est toujours devant un événement
inattendu
dick le hasard n'existe pas
jamais un événement attendu
vous buvez votre verre à la terrasse
d'un café
vous ne rencontrer personne que vous
connaissez
vous n'allez pas vous dire tiens comme
par hasard aujourd'hui je n'ai rencontré
personne que je connaissais
vous allez vous dire bah oui
mal
il ya plus
que je ne connais pas que deux personnes
que je connais
sont particulières pour que je m'étonne
de ne rencontrer personne que je
connaisse
vous n'allez même faire la réflexion
pareil quand personne au téléphone alors
vous étiez en train de penser à elle
quand on est en train de penser à
quelqu'un et que cette personne nous
appelle pile à ce moment là
ça fait bizarre
on a l'impression d'avoir un pouvoir
magique
on a peut-être un pouvoir magique allez
savoir
mais le fait est que quand on à
quelqu'un et que ce quelqu'un ne nous
appelle pas
on ne se fait pas la remarque
on ne fait pas
art quand le hasard nous met dans une
situation ordinaire
d'où cette situation ou s'il ne se passe
rien on ne pense pas au hasard et s'il
se passe quelque chose
c'est que le hasard n'existe pas
c'est le serpent qui la queue
et puis il faut ajouter autres onze qui
est que le hasard on l'interprète
toujours en référence à soi même
ce sont les hasards que nous vivons
personnellement qui ont du sens à nos
yeux
parce que quand on vit une situation
hasardeuse extraordinaire
on a la sensation que tout l'univers
s'est mobilisée pour nous
qu'il s'est mobilisée pour converger à
ce point précis
on a l'impression d'être littéralement
le centre de l'univers
donc est ce que vous allez dire quand
vous allez faire l'expérience d'une
coïncidence
vous allez dire c'est un signe
celle destin
vous allez vous dire qu'il y a raison à
cette rencontre
vous vous direz par exemple cette
personne va jouer un rôle dans ma vie
elle partie de mon chemin d'évolution
elle est une pièce de mon puzzle
personnel
c'est ça l'ambiance philosophique
général de la conception finalistes du
hasard
la notion de signes
la notion de sens
d'ailleurs j'en profite
sémantique
arles de signes il faut bien voir de
quoi on parle
timo logiquement un signe c'est ce qui
signifie
autrement dit un signe c'est ce qui est
porteur d'une signification
et le mot signe est intéressant parce
qu'un signe c'est aussi un geste
faire un signe de la main un signe de la
tête
c'est envoyer une information à
quelqu'un
et donc quand on parle de signe le plus
souvent ça sous-entend que quelque chose
nous fait signe
que l'univers que dieu que le carmin
nous dit quelque chose
qu'il s'adresse
personnellement
et donc danser non
si les coïncidences ont un sens
c'est parce qu'elles sont des points
d'intersection visible de la causalité
de quoi ça donne qu'une coïncidence
c'est la rencontre entre deux séries
causal apparemment indépendante
vraiment puisque à proprement parler
aucune série causal n'est totalement
indépendante des autres
toutes les séries causal sont imbriquées
les unes dans les autres
mais quand deux séries causal se croiser
quand deux chaîne de causalité
convergent en un point d'intersection
qui a du sens pour nous
on est obligé d'y voir un signe
j'ai dit voir davantage qu'une simple
intersection causale
assistez à une coïncidence
système a une conjonction d'événements
improbables
c'est comme voir la main du destin
décembre dans le décor pour modifier la
pièce
c'est comme surprendre dieu en pleine
écriture du scénario
d'où la phrase qu'on attribue einstein
le hasard c'est dieu qui se promènent
incognito
dieu se promènent incognito autrement
dit la volonté qui passe par le hasard
la volonté qui prend le fait mans du
hasard
si dieu est couvert
les avant d'en venir un petit rappel
nécessaire
c'est que avant d'être un message de
l'univers ou avant d'être le point
d'intersection de deux séries causale
hazard
d'abord une question mathématique
l'idée
est les probabilités révèle et que je
voudrais prendre le temps de vous
montrer
c'est que le hasard n'est finalement pas
si mme hasardeuse qu'il en a l'air
alors je sais beaucoup d'entre-vous
n'aime pas les maths mais je vous
rassure on va rester sur du très basique
pile ou face
on est bien d'accord que si vous jouez à
pile ou face la probabilité de tomber
sur piles et la probabilité de tomber
surface est la même
50 50
on appelle
sont des cui probabilité
probabilité égale pour chaque résultat
mais avoir une chance 2 de fer pile ou
face
ça ne veut pas dire que vous allez
forcément faire pile puis face puis pile
puis face etc
on parle de probabilités théorique
une chance sur 2 c'est une probabilité
théorique
donc supposons que vous fassiez 10
lancers
en théorie on devrait avoir 5 x peel et
sainte foy face
mais dans les faits on en sait du tout
peut-être que vous allez faire cinq fois
puis les cinq fois face mais peut-être
que vous allez faire trois fois piles et
cette fois face
ou dix fois pis les héros x face
toutes les combinaisons sont possibles
maintenant imaginons qu'au lieu de 10
lancers vous fassiez sans lancer
vous lancer la pièce sang froid
a priori pas différent ce
encore vous ferez peut-être 60 x piles
et 40 fois phase où vous ferez 90 10 ou
75 25 bref là encore tout est possible
et toujours selon ce raisonnement vous
pouvez faire mille lancé dix mille lancé
un million de lancer
vous ne savez pas quel score vous allez
obtenir
vous ne savez pas quel pourcentage de
piles et quel pourcentage de face vous
allez faire
et bien
et si
vous pouvez le savoir
vous pouvez le savoir parce que là
encore il existe une loi
elle la loi des grands nombres
et cette loi nous dit que plus on répète
une expérience aléatoire
une expérience dont le résultat dépend
du hasard
et plus la moyenne des résultats obtenus
va coïncider avec la probabilité
théorique
hi fi
vous allez lancer la pièce
plus vous allez obtenir une moyenne des
résultats proches de 50 50
et ça c'est incroyable
et pourquoi cette incroyable c'est
incroyable parce qu'on ne s'explique pas
pourquoi ce résultat
c'est incroyable parce qu'on ne comprend
pas pourquoi le fait de répéter une
expérience aléatoire temps à créer de l'
équilibre dans les résultats
temps à créer de l'ordre
pourquoi une expérience aléatoire
répéter un million de fois doit elle
avoir un résultat égal à sa probabilité
théorique
ça c'est une vraie question
et il faut bien comprendre de quoi on
parle quand on parle de la loi des
grands nombres
arles un principe mathématique
d'une abstraction mathématiques à savoir
un taux de probabilité un coefficient de
probabilités et on est en train de dire
que le fait de reproduire une expérience
aléatoire dans la réalité
tant à nous rapprocher de sa probabilité
théorique
comme s'il y avait un canal qui faisait
communiqué le monde physique avec le
monde mathématiques
s'il existait une loi qui fait que la
réalité se moule sur les mathématiques
c'est ça qui est stupéfiant
par ce qu'intuitivement on pourrait très
bien images n'est que sur un million de
lancer
on est 30 % de piles et 70% de face
ça paraît pas tellement aberrant
et bien si
à l'échelle statistiques
un million de lancer 70 30 c'est
totalement abérrant
un million de lancer on est sur du 50 50
et donc ce que nous dit la loi des
grands nombres
c'est que le a art et prévisible
et donc à ce titre
le hasard n'est plus totalement due au
hasard
la loi des grands nombres
c'est ce qui fait que les casinos font
des bénéfices
la règle numéro 1 au casino c'est que le
client continue à jouer
car plus il joue plus il berre
pourquoi
parce que les probabilités sont du côté
du casino
à la roulette vous n'avez pas trente six
cases
vous en avez 37
parce qu'il y a le zéro
et ça change tout
parce qu'avec
as 18 case noire et 18,4 rouge c'est 50
ans de gagner
mais avec 37 case on tombe à 48,6 %
autrement dit la loi des grands nombres
nous dit que le casino est obligé de
gagner
parce qu il al avantage mathématique
donc il n'ya pas de hasard
au fond un casino c'est peut-être le
seul endroit où le hasard est absent
et donc on en a
si d'extraordinaire le hasard fois ce
qu'il ya de plus chaotique est ce qu'il
y a de plus organisé
de plus imprévisible
et en même temps de plus régulier
car tout se passe comme si le hasard
la forme dispersé de l'ordre
tout se passe si le hasard
avait une direction
et que la part des organisations du
hasard
n'était en fait qu'une illusion temporel
une illusion qui se dissout
pétitions
eagle voyez le monde comme un
déploiement
déploiement de la matière
déploiement de la ville
déploiement de l'esprit
il était convaincu que la raison guide
est le réel
et donc que l'histoire
avait un sens
derrière le chaos des événements
derrière le chaos des passions humaines
et du hasard
il y à une logique
il y a une raison
avec un grand r
l'histoire
c'est le déploiement de la raison
universelle dans le temps
c'est l'esprit du monde qui s'incarne
dans les événements
pour parvenir à un but
l'a conçu ce
histoire c'est le monde qui prend
progressivement
conscience de lui-même
et pour parler à cet objectif final
qu'est la conscience la raison passe
partout les chemins praticables du réel
elle passe par nous les êtres humains
mais elle passe aussi par le hasard
les hasards ne sont pas des hasards pour
eagle
hill sont les chemins tournée que la
raison universelle
emprunte pour s'accomplir
le hasard
c'est la raison universelle qui trébuche
et qui en trébuchant
se fait remarquer
et quand nous sommes confrontés au
hasard
l'étonnement que nous éprouvons
c'est l'étonnement issus de la
conscience que tous les événements sont
liés
c'est une piqûre de rappel
de l'interdépendance
des éléments du monde
l'étonnement dû au hasard
c'est le claquement de doigts devant nos
yeux
qui nous dit
soit if
soit
car le monde parle
et te parle en permanence
tu ne l'entend la plupart du temps
car tu es trop occuper
tacon
ray
tout le temps
mais si tu lève les yeux
ou si tu tends l'oreille
tu entendras le monde
en train de s'adresser à toi
tu verras le monde
en train de sac lire sous tes yeux
et si tu y plonge toute la conscience
tu deviendras toi même le monde qui
s'accomplit
et s'il faut pour attirer
ils ont
envoyé des signes
s'il faut de faire signe
le monde tu en verras des signes
et ne te demandera rien d'autre
qu'un sourire
quand tu les paies recevra
je vous remercie
[Musique]